Hi.
I look like I'm...
Look like I'm saying no.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no,
no.
No, no, no.
Guys.
Guys, I'm sad.
I'm sad today I was supposed to be VR chat and for some reason it's I don't know I tried everything I don't know basically basically uh uh the valve index was not showing up and so therefore I couldn't hear anything.
Why is my hand?
I couldn't hear anything.
And so then what's the what what would be fine?
I can't hear anything.
So it's fine.
I'm over it.
It's fine.
But it has kind of put me in a
so sorry I don't even feel like not that I don't feel like streaming but I don't feel like I'm gonna be any fun so today instead we'll play Clover Pit
Clover we're gonna go gambling gamble my gamble my worries away so I'm sorry but I'm at 3d a little bit if you were looking forward to me wiggling in 3d you'll get it a little bit at least but don't if you see any anything that's weird with the 3d pay no attention i had no chance to set it up really so
okay we're gambling Um, I played this game a little bit since, uh, since the last time I played.
Oh, my mind of, I might have played a little bit more.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah.
Want to see jazz hands?
I'm also, I'm also karate chopping today.
I have no hands.
Well, I have hands.
I have no...
I can't move my fingers.
I'm karate chopping.
Just heads!
Anyway.
Let's see.
Sorry guys.
I feel like I'm gonna be so low energy.
We'll see.
So...
Um...
So, I might have unlocked all the drawers.
I might have unlocked all the drawers.
And I might have gotten these, uh...
What are these cards called?
Also, thank you guys for the super chats.
It's my birthday.
My just happy birthday!
saying happy birthday i feel i'll be so depressed but happy happy birthday i hope it's a good one i hope it's better than my day uh these memory cards i got these i got these but right now we're just on like we're vanilla we're still vanilla and i've gotten a couple well let's see um i've Unlocked a couple things.
Actually, what am I missing?
Placeholder for a joke referencing yesterday's game that I'm too creeped out by to tell...
What does that mean?
Here's a pink soupa.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
See, I still have quite a bit.
Seven.
I still have quite a bit that I need to unlock, so, you know.
Whoa, wow, my arm is crazy.
Still quite a bit.
Unlock.
Yeah.
Have you escaped yet?
No, I haven't escaped.
So maybe that's...
See, see, actually, I don't...
Oh, wait, I have to collect all the bones, right?
But I don't know what this key does.
So that's your final reward.
I still haven't decided when you'll get it.
I had I had like many bones at one point I have many bones I had like maybe four bones and then but I died really fast because it gave me like three bones and then I bought a bone and I had four bones and I was like wow my debt is huge So, uh, yeah.
But, I don't know, I just kind of want to play.
Um, uh, I just kind of want to play.
Head empty.
No, no thoughts.
Just gamble.
Jackpot.
That's what I'm thinking.
Nah.
First time tuning in.
Oh no, Hiro!
I'm sorry!
I'm so...
This is like the worst time to see me.
This is maybe the worst impression ever.
Maybe.
Oh, but thank you.
Thank you so much for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alrighty.
Well, do I want anything?
I'm gonna grab that.
I don't think I've tried it before.
Hmm.
Hi, dog.
I'm just happy to spend some koala tea time with you.
Koala tea time.
Tea time!
What did this do again?
Sorry.
Oh, no.
I'm, like, in that kind of mood where I just do stuff and I don't know what it even means.
Get to school.
What happens if you rotate on my head?
Like that?
Why am I disappearing?
Where am I going?
Wait, why is my skirt flipped up?
Oh, excuse me.
Oh gosh.
3D.
3D, man.
For some reason, it won't let me turn anymore.
Guys, can I show you...
Can I show you what's going on underneath the desk?
Can I show you?
Yeah?
Okay.
One moment, please.
Hold on.
I want to make a better...
I'm gonna... Ah!
Ah, hold on, I want to make a better face.
Ah!
Wait, I wonder if it'll show up here.
This is peak.
This is ideal gaming.
This is how I play the game.
Guys?
Isn't this how you guys game at home?
Okay, we'll just keep it like this for now, then.
Alright, press the button.
Slam!
Wait, what does that mean again?
Sorry, hold on.
For every round, uh...
You gain one extra spin with seven log.
Oh, so it's like...
This is like the coin, but bad.
Oh, it's ancient coin, that's why.
I wonder if I can extend even more.
Oh!
Everybody was kung fu fighting!
Hiya!
Sorry, I'm blocking the spinner.
About to hit that thunderstabbing.
Oh, sorry, I accidentally clicked on something.
I'm trying to exit out of it.
I'm just doing the splits now.
Okay, this is, this works.
This works, this works.
I wish I could turn though.
There she goes.
You didn't see anything sussy, right?
Hold on.
I can't figure out how to turn!
Guys.
Everything is so bad today.
I can't even play the game.
I'm so distracted.
I figured it out!
Where'd my leg go?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, this is better.
Okay, what we're doing?
Grabbing my money?
Depositing my money?
Deposit?
And spin!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Yeah, yeah!
Just do it!
Pull!
Woohoo!
Paul!
Oh!
Oh.
Yippee!
Okay, cool.
Uh-oh.
I have one round left.
Thank you.
Have you guys ever lost on the first round?
Couldn't be.
me um we have three i'm just gonna um oh but it'll be so little wait what is this broken calculator patterns trigger one more time for this spin nah no no yeah no i ain't no quitter yeah losing on the tutorial wait what do you guys think broken calculator might be good later This is gonna give me only 22.
Train is good for start.
What does a train do again?
Oh!
Yeah.
We'll do a train, and I'm gonna buy that just because.
Beep, beep.
Thank you.
I finished early, but that's okay.
Lucky charms at the store are discounted by two until next restock.
Is there anything that I want?
This...
I've...
Oh.
I'll...
Okay, hold on.
Sorry, guys.
I'm going to turn myself back around.
I'm sitting crisscross applesauce.
Oh, never mind.
I'm not turning myself.
Oops.
Uh...
One second.
Hmm.
Um.
This is good.
Actually, how is my hand?
Everything is bad.
Okay, cool.
I don't know any.
I don't think I want any of these.
Do I book at home culture zone or main store?
Oh, both are good.
I do like the Culture Zone store though.
It's really big.
It's nice.
Um...
Wiggles.
I'm wiggling.
Do you guys want to see me do the worm?
Wait one second.
One second.
Why am I backwards?
okay this is my vr stuff on the floor here i have to kick it away i don't know if you can hear me this is my vr stuff on the floor i've never done the worm before
how did it look
She's so talented!
Okay, anyway, back to game.
Don't look at how I'm sitting.
Don't look at how I'm sitting, okay.
Why am I lagging?
Why is everything hate me today?
Why?
Man.
Oh, why did it make me so big?
Okay.
We're back.
Sorry, I'm so distracted because I can't focus.
Okay, uh, be right back.
Wait, oh, be right back.
Be right back.
There we go.
Okay, I had to realign my thing.
Let's see.
I don't feel like anything here was...
the lemon would be good.
I could get it for free, I guess.
Maybe every time I...
Why did I do that?
I did, I did it wrong.
Why, why did I do that?
Let's just, let's just do this.
Why not?
Ah.
Cool.
Oh, geez.
Anyway, um...
Oh, wait.
Let's deposit my money.
Let's go!
Gambling!
Hi!
And hi!
Oh!
Oh, wow.
Okay.
This is one of those days, guys.
Nice!
Again, again, again, again, again!
Looks like I'm dancing Gagnum style.
How?
Oisha.
That wasn't so bad.
Could have been way worse.
We'll keep going, though.
Thank you for the red.
Hello.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I forgot to press.
Oh, wait.
I guess it's fine.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm supposed to be playing VR chat right now.
Wow, that was pretty good.
That was pretty good.
Thank you guys for the...
For the...
What do you call them?
Why am I lagging?
For the...
Gifted.
I'm lagging iron.
well yeah i'm lagging everywhere i don't know you guys i think i don't have it in me to go today i don't think i have it in me to keep streaming
i'm so i'm so sorry
i thought i think i'm just so brain fogged right now because it was one issue and then it was dealing with another issue with the vr and then and then uh
yeah you guys want me to do another trick in 3d you guys want me to do more tricks in 3d I already did the worm I could do something else for you guys I'm so sorry I feel like I've I'm so sorry.
Do a cartwheel?
I don't, I can't, I don't know how to do those, but I can try.
I can try.
One moment, please.
Your patience is appreciated.
Okay.
I'm gonna be cartwheeling here in a clover pit.
baby in the clover pit you're gonna see you all see the cartwheel of your lives okay whoa whoa whoa whoa wait ah sorry guys hold on I'm having some technical difficulties one moment one second one second one second I'm so sorry Okay, hold on.
I'm so sorry.
One second, please.
Don't look at that.
Please don't look.
Okay, I might be fixed in three, two, one.
Okay, that didn't fix me.
One moment, please.
Ah!
Okay, we're almost there.
Uh-oh.
Guys.
No matter what I do, it doesn't fix.
Uh.
Okay, hold on.
Uh-oh.
Guys.
Uh.
No matter what I do, it doesn't fix.
Hmm.
Well, we're doing it live.
Okay, let me do a cartwheel now.
I'm backing up.
Ta-da!
How was that?
Can I not...
There we go.
I'm just gonna look at you guys like this.
Well, I hope you guys enjoyed the show.
And, um...
Don't forget to like and subscribe.
For more...
Minky activities.
And, uh...
Yeah, I sure hope you liked this.
Happy Halloween, everybody!
Happy Halloween!
Okay, I'm gonna go now.
Nah, I'm gonna go now.
Bye.